i'm jason j rise fonseca of
riseonline.com i offer empire design for
ambitious creatives and today's one
minute monday is let good things happen
so a lot of you
might be struggling you might wake up
and and be thinking i'm a good person i
have lots to offer i'm running a
business and it's way too hard i deserve
more i deserve more clients i deserve
more leads i deserve more dollars
and it's just not happening
and i've been there it's painful
it feels like you're dying inside
what if there was an easier way
what if you could relax take it easy do
something fun and let good things happen
i was
posting on evan carmichael's forums
uh and i i found out he was hosting a
fundraiser for little nicki's a cafe in
toronto
that had a bus driven through it they
could use a hand
even at the time
i was
practically desperate
i was on i had my last ten dollars
literally and i took it and i went
to support little nicki's
and when i was at nikki's
i met evan and a bunch of entrepreneurs
and i shook his hand
and everything changed that day and from
that point on we
worked out collaborations
i started rising and i want that for you
too you deserve it you deserve more and
there are easier ways to get it
and no one will tell you this it's not
common knowledge but
letting it go
and focusing on something better
helps
together we rise
believe
you